hi I'm Andrea Griffin and I'll be giving
a talk on oil from tech on online
courses okay so my name is Andrea
Griffin today I'm going to talk about
whole firm tech in online course
platforms so the first question you
might have is what all that means and
why I'm here so first of all I'm gonna
introduce a publicly available course
that details everything that I'm going
through here so at some point I'll show
you the Lincoln you can follow along if
you want to
so first what brought me here growing up
I learned that I thought I might really
like to teach and I really liked math
and so I became a high school math
teacher I didn't quite like that
experience but one of the main reasons
why I didn't is because I felt like
there was more I could do and I didn't
have the technology to help me do that
and so I left that profession and I
wanted to help teachers teach by
building educational tools so help
learners learn and help teachers teach
and so I went and got a master's in
computer science and after I received my
master's I attended well from summer
school and this is when I learned most
about the Wolfram language and became
really interested in the power of the
Wolfram language and excited about using
it and so my goal really changed to
building some tools using the power of
the Wolfram language I became a Wolfram
employee and I helped run the Wolfram
summer programs well from summer camps
and summer school and a camp in
Australia and I'm still a part-time
employee at Wolfram and I still help
with those programs but as a part of
being a Wolfram employee at these
programs I met a lot of people and one
of the people I met knew some professors
that were looking for tools to be built
and so he hired
as a MIT employee and so I've been
spending the past couple of years making
tools for educators at MIT so before I
go on any further I just want to see by
a show of hands if I just keep talking
about LMS and learning management
systems how many of you are familiar
with that term okay and how about LTI
okay much less that's what I expected
so a learning management system you all
kind of know is something like EDX
Coursera Moodle blackboard canvas if
you've been to a college recently a lot
of them are using them they are
basically ways that they can present
instruction they might have forms of
discussion and assessment which means
most of them have a grade book and
that's kind of important in this
discussion so if I want to create tools
and have them be used in the classroom
those tools need to be able to
communicate with these LMS systems that
are being used in the classrooms and
that's where LTI comes in LTI is
learning tools interoperability and the
premise of LTI is that it's a standard
that people that are making educational
tools can follow and know that the LMS
is or will understand what those things
are talking about so LTI is a standard
for like identifying users that come to
that the LMS and it also helps with the
tool communicate with the gradebook so
if I was going to meet my goal to help
learners learning teachers teach and I
wanted to use the Wolfram language I
need to know that the LMS is going to be
able to communicate with my tools and so
I needed the I needed a Wolfram language
LTI translator I needed to be able to
usable from Wolfram language following
the LTI standards so that it can
communicate properly with the LMS
systems and so that's what we did at MIT
and now I'm creating a bunch of tools
for educators there that talk to these
systems that they're here to using so
that's what brought me here last year I
talked about that package that connected
the Wolfram language to the LMS and that
talk is online and recorded and so I
didn't want to redo this talk but you
can go back and get some more
information about some of the things I
might skip through this time around and
that's just on the tech conference
website so last year what I talked about
was a couple of projects that I worked
on at MIT an artifact generator and a
gallery generator and then I'm also a
part of a research study where we're
studying I'll go into the details of
that later and then I also walked
through the functions within the LTI
package that we created and so some of
these functions identify users like
their role if they're an administrator
or student their email address a hashed
ID and it identifies course information
so we're within the course you may be it
will send grades back to the gradebook
within the LMS system and wolfram forms
are a little more complicated to make
LTI compliant and so we also created a
function that makes those forms LTI
compliant so you can use a Wolfram form
in your classroom ask students questions
and it will know what they answer you
could include a grader and then send
that grade back to the gradebook so
what's new since last year we spent this
year finishing up projects and creating
more documentation and guides for that
package that I had talked about last
year and so that's pretty much what
we're going to go through today is just
the documentation and then we also
created something that I think is the
most interesting of this talk which is a
way for students to
in a notebook on the LMS and be graded
and send that information back so we'll
get to that in a second so if any of you
would like to this is the link I've left
it up for a minute but I'm gonna leave
and go to that course it's much smaller
up there so this course is to
specifically talk about Wolfram LTI
tools and how to develop them and it
also lists the tools that I've made so
we talked about how to get anything
Wolfram into your course so if you make
a manipulate how you can have that show
up in your LMS or anything like that we
talk about what Wolfram is and I don't
need to go through that with all of you
because you know what manipulates are
when I say that and if you don't you'll
learn more here and then we also talked
about what LTI is how to add LTI tools
into your course we talked about the
couple of projects that we had already
finished and how you can just by click
button add those projects to your own
course for your own use and then this is
the tool we've been using for the
research study which we'll go into a
little bit later and then this is the
documentation for how to make your own
Wolfram LTI compliant tools and add them
to your course and so some of these
functions like getting the students
email address and information on how to
save what they might submit in a forum
or something like that
are all in here so I'm going to just
quickly go through some of those things
so adding Wolfram to your course is very
simple you can make a cloud object
there's many many ways to do that and
then generate an iframe by using embed
code and then you can put that iframe
straight into your course most LMS to
support iframes and all that information
on how to
each of those steps is within this
course so if you do go here later you
can learn more there
there are also steps specifically for
EDX because that's what we use at MIT
but this should easily switch over to
any other LMSs because that's what LTI
is for so making your course Wolfram LTI
compliant basically the main step here
is you have to add a path an LTI
passport to your course and these are
the steps to find that in EDX this is
how you would add a Wolfram LTI tool to
your course and it's very pretty simple
although these images aren't showing up
right now okay and this is one of the
projects that I worked on last year it
was a gallery generator so this
instructor wanted their students to she
wanted to give them a prompt and they
would fill in certain character ttan
answers and submit an image and that
would generate a gallery tile and in the
end she wanted all of the students
gallery titles to show up I can't see
thee there we go
to show up in a gallery altogether so
this is an example of what that might
look like and so we made this last year
and I had presented on it but this year
what we added was a tool installer so
anytime we now make an LTI tool I will
from a tool out of Wolfram language we
have this installer where you can fill
in your Wolfram LTI passport and make
your own copy of this notebook and when
you click on this button down here it
will add that tool to your own cloud so
you can use it in your own course and
give you instructions on how to add it
to your course another project that we
worked on last year was a workplan
generator so this is another tool you
can just add to your course this is
having the students reflect on what they
why they join the course what they might
do there and stuff like that and then it
generates a printout so that they can
put it on their desk and remind
themselves and it's also a great way for
teachers to understand why students took
the course this is actually the code
that I've been using to do our research
study so this is all here and available
to you if you'd like to use it it's not
as well built out as those other ones
it's not just a click and add but we're
working on that to get there okay and so
this is how you can make a Wolfram LTI
tool so to make just a regular to take
and manipulate and add it to a course
you just need to cloud deploy it and
then make an iframe out of it and add
that to your course a Wolfram LTI tool
is almost just as easy so you just need
to cloud deploy a delayed object that
gets our package and now you'll have all
of the functions that you need to do
certain things like identify the student
and save their work in specific places
and so this is the bulk of what all of
the tools look like and then you would
just take this URL and import and put it
into your course so here are some
functions in the package I'm not going
to go through all of them because that's
in my talk from last year but this one
just makes sure that the students
actually signed in this one gets their
user ID so you can see here is an
example of it working this is my
specific user ID for this course and so
you can identify the student maybe save
their answers to a forum discussion in
there based on their ID me good one
this one gets roles so you can see here
that I'm currently logged in as a
student in this particular course but if
I go up to the top and change to a staff
member
oh it goes back to that other page
that's an EDX thing if I change to a
staff member now it knows that I'm an
administrator and this is good because
if you make a tool and you want the
administrators to see all of the
students submissions but you only want
the student to see their own submission
you can make that you can make you can
make the tool run differently based on
who's looking at it okay and then it
says this is the big one so if you're
curious how what how you might grade a
student on something and then send it to
the gradebook well it's just LT I send
grade so right here you can see LT I
send grade one and then these are a part
of your passport that you set up to make
your course LTI compliant it's just two
strings that you have to know for that
course and so this is going to send a
grade of one and you can see down here
I've run this before so it changed my
grade for this section of the course to
one okay
so these are some examples of how you
can use forums to do these things so you
can see here my grade is 0.15 for this
forum allows the student to just change
their grade to whatever they want it to
be
so I'll just say 0.81 not that great but
I'm pretty good and if i refresh this
course you can now see that they grade
got changed and that just all that was
was a Wolfram forum so if you're
familiar with Wolfram forums this is
pretty simple that gets the package and
then does the LTI centigrade with that
chosen grade and then we just needed to
make an LTI tool URL for that object so
this is the URL for the forum and this
is just launches the form as an LTI
compliant form
okay so this is the Big Kahuna of this
talk we finally cracked this and we'll
be using it in the spring
I believe so this is a Wolfram notebook
directly in a course that a learner
could go to and again we've given them
the power to just choose whichever grade
they want by setting X equal to that
number so you can see here my grade is
currently 0.5 out of 1 I want it to be
perfect so I'll set X equal to that
number and then I can hit submit for
grading it says that it updated it here
it did update the grade but these are
not they don't update dynamically so
again I have to refresh the page and you
can see there that it changed to 1 and
so what this oh and I changed the staff
use unchanged and so this is a really
simple example but you can add any type
of grading criteria so you could make a
notebook ask your students to do certain
coding things within that notebook look
through the notebook to see what they've
done grade them on that task and then it
will automatically be sent to the
gradebook and it's all within the LMS
that they normally work in without
taking them outside of it and so this is
the code that did that so this is the
notebook that you saw originally this is
the grading criteria it just checks to
see if it's a number or not and then if
it is leave it that leave it that way
otherwise give them a zero so if I
changed this one this X to like a it
will change my grade to zero and again
it's just launched notebook with some
identifiers for the LTI information and
that's it for that so those are some of
the new things from last year the other
thing that happened that we've finished
from last year we were conducting this
research study that I've kind of touched
upon I'm going to quickly hand
off to my colleague Kyle who couldn't
make it this year but he talks really
nicely about this thing so first he's
talking about manipulates which you're
again you're all familiar with so this
is what we're hoping to engage students
and and this is not the first time we've
tried to engage students with
interactive widgets but this is the
first time where I'm trying to
understand what about that is actually
engaging and does it in fact lead to
better outcomes so the two hypotheses
that are the two things that feed my
hypothesis are that in the 1940s there
was this amazing study where they just
put some shapes on the screen and then
had them move around in a little video
and people anthropomorphize they gave
them human emotions and human attributes
and then I'll talk about this one in a
second so I'll let you watch this and
see if just by movement you can give
some sort of story to what's happening
here
so by this point people usually don't
like the big triangle and this is an
amazingly universal response so you can
test it with children and adults and
different cultures and it's very clear
that this triangle is intimidating and
bullying the smaller triangle and that's
not actually what's happening these are
literally just shapes moving on a screen
but we've given this entire emotional
story to it
so just by movement we can engage the
emotional system we can engage the
humans narrative system in understanding
what's happening so yeah you get a
little celebration once they get out so
the next thing and this is really great
timing so this is a Prakash child so my
colleague Pollan has just talked about a
child who has given who has vision
restored their congenitally blind and
then their vision was restored later and
we want to understand how the brain
starts to interpret information now that
it has visual stuff coming through and
so this is a child who's been asked to
identify the shape on the screen yes
what shape do you see and the kid says I
can't make it out and then you start to
move the triangle
and now the triangle has become this
emergent object so instead of just
giving people these static images
instead of giving people just a bit
static images we want them to engage in
movement so that we can get that kind of
visual learning process that mapping a
physical phenomenon onto the visual
cortex especially at MIT right now Mary
throwing these ball you talk so if we
return to our question we have Mary
throwing these balls and there's this
tension especially at MIT right now
about how do I engage students in doing
this type of work I can have them do
math by hand we think that there is
definitely some value in that I can have
them solve it using a computer algebra
system or just coding it computer
programming or I can have them interact
with the widget and have them play with
this thing and learn visually and these
are three equivalently engaging ways to
learn for different people and we want
to know which one and how to give
different learners so that they engage
so that's kind of the premise of the
study that we were working on and it was
somewhat impossible to make this study
happen without some of the technology
that we had developed and one of the
reasons is because we did a 2x2
factorial design where each student in a
that took the course they were a part of
a specific group and this is the
breakdown of the groups they got either
an interactive widget or coding
instruction or not and the LMS systems
have a B testing and that kind of thing
but we wanted to make sure that every
group was equally separated so that
there wasn't all physics experts in the
first group in all physics experts in
the fourth group and then none of the
other ones knew anything about the topic
at hand and so we finally so using the
LTI system we were able to ask them
questions upfront grade their work and
place them into certain groups using a
clinical trial algorithm in real time
and so the results of our study came
through and what happened is we didn't
have enough participation in each of the
groups to come up with any results so I
know you're really helping me hear about
if these interactive visual widgets help
with learning but we don't know the
answer yet and but we did come up with
this text stack and I'm running out of
time so I I won't send that through but
the tech is what allowed us to be able
to even run the study in the first place
so what's next we've changed the premise
of our study we were looking at both
visual widgets encoding and how that
changes how students learn in the
classroom and we've changed our premise
so now just looking at the visual
widgets which allowed us to break it
down into two groups instead of five and
then we're also adding coding
instruction into the residential version
of this class because this is an online
class and so we get in 2020 we should be
able to then take that coding
instruction and incorporate it into this
study as a part of this study we also
ask students questions using a
manipulate so we gave them an empty I'm
going to be late and said move the
slider to a certain point that
represents the answer to this question
and we were able to use that the course
actually just ended like yesterday so we
were able to use that in our pre and
post-testing but I don't have that quite
yet built into the LTI package so that
should be coming soon we're also
creating computational labs for a
multivariable calculus class where we'll
be using that launch notebook thing that
grades the students so we haven't quite
used that yet but hopefully next year
we'll be able to talk about that and
then I also I'm just working on a phase
diagram Explorer for the material
science department so if any of you are
interested in that we can talk about
that later and that's all I have for
today
you
[Applause]